not many people know this at Keanu
Reeves you've trained as a ballroom
dancer no I didn't yes you did no I
didn't yes you did no no no I took some
Ballroom lesson there you go what did I
just say not training wait but why
didn't you decide to want to learn
Ballroom
um it sounded like fun I'm sensing it
wasn't it was well it was thrilling
actually I remember one of the first
lessons I had
um when I did the waltz with the partner
and oh my gosh I mean I got high it was
amazing that first time doing and she
led and just [__] oh excuse my life
I'm just like it was amazing thrilling
to be moving through space like that and
yeah it was it was it was pretty special
and then did the foxtrot and some Tango
and if you kept it up absolutely no no
no no fun as it was yeah yeah when I
trained for the first Matrix film right
they had us kind of training we trained
for four months and for four months I'd
worked with the other actors and he
couldn't hit anybody no one could hit
everything was about safety and then the
first day of filming the guy tells me
okay kick him
I was like yeah kick him hit him he was
a stun person but it was just it was
just funny that you guys have trained me
for four months and I'm not and then I
couldn't hit him I was like I can't hit
him
and then finally the stunt I was just
look if you don't hit me we have to keep
doing this get it over with and we're
done
see that's true
he could have taken your head off
you're a fan aren't you yeah
did you think he was going to be here
yes I did I'm so sorry so I wouldn't
have come and find it you're in a lovely
white box so um and beautifully lit
so let's get to it the first Matrix
movie you know when we went to see it we
all got it we blew our minds it was
amazing but when you read the script
could you know things like you know the
being suspended animation and the bullet
time and stuff did any of that make
sense to you reading a script kinda I
mean it really made sense when I when I
when I met Lana and Lily
um and they showed me a pre-vis for
bullet time and uh you know for me it
was just really exciting to be a part of
something that was new in cinema you
know uh changing perspective playing
with time and all of the uh kind of
technical computer generated support
that that that image that event yeah
um for me it was cool just to you know
be able to dodge bullets
in this film you are on a horse and was
that again was your idea it was another
Vision yes I had another Vision after
chapter two John Wick is running out of
Central Park and I said Chad I have a
vision and he was like what Keanu and I
said
I want to ride a horse why don't I ride
a horse I'm trying to escape and so he
said that's a good idea and so began the
training because with John Wick he can't
just ride a horse
yeah I have to come off the saddle
you're supposed to fall under held onto
the pommel excuse me it's fine and then
it shoots them does
um but uh but when we were training I I
couldn't really do it and I fell
um but as you do and so then they had to
create something to make it safe and so
they did this contraption that was like
this truck with some beams and then a
gentleman on a wire so I was picked in
case I fell off the horse while we were
on the streets and so that happened a
couple of times the horse took off and I
was like falling and then they pulled me
up and but uh so that was nice if you
try to imagine what Keanu looked like at
16. Oh no you're doing this yes we are
we are what's weird is you look exactly
the same no you do you do this is Keanu
age I think 16s 17. doing a commercial
for uh is it Coca-Cola yeah
it was a really big deal actually for me
it's one of my first jobs and it was a
big deal here you are okay enjoy
[Music]
who's your coach my dad
was that the american commercial that
was the Canadian commercial
and that was one of my first experiences
where I actually had the director you
know where you have to drink the the
drink and they keep saying no not like
that you know and you're there for an
hour and it's like you're on a desert
island you're dying of first now see the
line Coke no
and then it kept going and going until
finally it went to anyway
this is something because I I thought it
mustn't be America because I watched
that a few times now you lose the race
like
drink a curler you two could lose
Jack here I know you're a big fan of
keanu's films like I am a huge fan of
yours I love John Wick Bill and Ted
Matrix like obviously as well you're a
man that is not afraid of a sequel but
one of my favorite movies of all time is
speed why did you turn down speed too
ah
very much
and uh speed two yeah at the time I just
uh
um I didn't respond to the script I
really wanted to work with Sandra
Bullock and and uh I just you know I
really love playing Jack Travis you know
I love speed and it was like okay a bus
okay we're going but now it's on an
ocean liner yeah
speed ocean liner
speed not feeling ocean noise but anyway
but it was really just the time in my
life and and where where the script was
and stuff I it wasn't against any of the
artists that I've you know involved with
the project but um at that time I'm sure
we've all had this kind of feeling
sometimes when things just don't feel
right and yeah and that was that was how
I was feeling and it was almost like in
real life you were dodging a bullet so
uh that's good
[Music]
[Applause]
talking off sequels much excitement or
well maybe is it true Bill and Ted three
yeah
all right give a tag still alive
[Applause]
this is a thing didn't happen you talked
about this yeah yeah the the writers had
a story
um and we're trying to make it yeah so
what like where are building Ted Knox
they must be well in their 50s now yeah
yeah it would be Bill and 10 in their
50s
I mean that just makes me laugh right
there like what happened to these guys
um but there was there's a cool story
basically they're supposed to write a
song to save the world and they haven't
done that
so the pressure of having to save the
world you know their marriages are
falling apart their kids are kind of mad
at them and and but then someone comes
from the future and tells them if they
don't write the song it's just not the
world now it's the universe and so they
have to save the universe because the
you know time is breaking apart and uh
so then elements of the
paste that person from there
yeah
three and you're in it
I can't get in a movie with him
you know
those movies okay you find someone some
clothes on I'll come in
the air guitar thing are you is that
something if you're ever in a bar and a
guitar song comes in do people just look
at you kind of like let's go into he's
going to yeah yeah which is kind of cool
in a way that it's still alive you know
so could you do it so you say accident
then then yeah you do that okay okay
I'm gonna use this like I'm training
like yeah you're doing a movie yeah
bad bad Keanu Reeves that was terrible
at your mom my mother your mother and
she was English wasn't she yeah and she
was a costume designer yeah she was yeah
but we've got a picture apparently oh my
gosh I know she designed what dolly is
wearing on this wow I love this show
it is but this outfit was in your house
oh yeah I I wore that for Halloween
are you no
hey I mean how did you there was some
room right yeah where did you go
wherever did you like did you go door to
door did you Trick and Treat him well I
wasn't like 14. you know I was 16.
whatever I do I got on public
transportation but the thing was I
didn't have the shoes so I had that
whole thing I had the ears I had the bow
tie I had the top I didn't have the
cufflink and then it was the stockings
that I didn't shave my legs and I was
wearing these really ratty sneakers and
then I was on the streetcar going to
this uh fat a Halloween party at the
performing arts high school that I went
to and did you have this with you I was
wearing winter I was there I was like
you'd have to have this video so people
knew just how cool your costume was I
know it was well made yeah
no no no come on
[Music]
awesome where did you guys find this
it's mine
we're used to seeing you in the Mean
Streets but this time John Wick goes
Global now is it actually the Sahara
Desert yes it's a remarkable place it
was the first time I'd ever been there
so when we see you walking in the desert
that is you in the Sahara that's me and
the Sahara with Halle Berry now I would
say even tonight it's not a bad day
even tonight you are more suitably
dressed for walking through the Sahara
than you are because like lace-up shoes
aren't a good idea I know but it's John
Wick
he's gotta change wouldn't he take his
tie off no no no we talked about like
you know does he wrap his coat around
his head it doesn't do all his survival
techniques no no no John Wick is walking
in the desert you know Keanu Reeves and
Halle Berry so you've got to think how
how could they be upstaged these dogs
are amazing they are spectacular now I
don't want to spare anyone's blushes or
I don't think this is a spoiler but
there is a lot of ball biting that goes
on yes in the film yeah they're attack
dogs ball biting ball balls right okay
oh right now is that just have they just
put some cheddar cheese down there how
do you get a dog to do that cheddar
cheese dogs love cheddar cheese sausage
and cheese yeah that's how you train
your dogs to do anything sausages and
cheese you don't want them to bite you
harder you want protection you know like
you don't want to entice them did you
have like stunt balls
but they're so sweet they're so smart
um and yeah and so once we got into the
action of it it's kind of like dog Foo
right so we have like carfu and John
Wick gunfu now there's dog food so they
become part of the action in him and
even though you're very famous you do
ride motorbikes don't you yes yeah but
like a lot is that your main way of
getting around yeah pretty much yeah a
little Norton Commando yeah English twin
sorry did you just say did you just say
a Norton Commander
in your legs because I can tell you at
least one person's sitting very close to
you is imagining exactly that right
[Applause]
rehearsal That's My Boy the jokes write
themselves
they're not going there but you do fall
off motorbikes a lot yeah I've had some
you know it's a weird thing I've had
some good luck and some bad luck you're
alive that's the good luck
the bad luck is I've got a fake tooth
I've got a huge scar here I've got a I
guess a plate in my neck about this but
that's not all just the motorcycles but
yeah I've come off the bike a few times
yeah and but wasn't there a time you
scarred your leg yeah that was the one
where a car pulled out in front of me
and and I was kind of trying to decide
this was just after I had the plate in
the neck and I was deciding it so I was
kind of about to hit the car
because I started to Veer but then the
car saw me and started to move and then
he stopped and then I was just like oh
man what am I getting so then I was
trying to decide whether to drop the
bike or to jump off the bike and go over
the car and then by the time I kind of
figured that all out
um I took the bumper off of his car and
I ended up sitting on the ground and
then that bike was just lying over there
and then my tooth was cut in half and I
had blood in my mouth and then the guy
came over and he was freaking out but I
was in shock so I was like it's okay
the thing about it is that I was getting
as I was sitting
my skin was open on my shin
and Bone White
is very white yeah it's like so I kept
touching it and my friend without it
like look how white that is
and so then this woman who came up said
it said everything okay and then she
kind of was there and the paramedics and
she was like is that Keanu Reeves and
he's like what can I have your autograph
thank you
[Music]